Now you make think it's a bunch of trouble to add all these comments into your
code but let me show you something. Here is a part of the documentation of the
java string class. When you scroll through it you'll see someone wrote a lot of
documentation here, and actually let me tell you who that someone was. You can
get the source code for the string class, it's a part of the java development
kit. So, here is a part of the actual source code, here is a method and over
here. The programmer wrote a pretty long java.comment and not just one. If you
scroll through this file, you will see that every method has a comment. Here's
another one and you'll see that every method has a comment so if the programmer
that give us java can write those comments, so can you.